excusez moi un trade vient de mettre en
pls bathium d'isla d'horreur ça fait
longtemps ça fait trois semaines on en a
marre de bien dormir des histoires
d'horreur nous manque squeeze calmez
vous je vous ai entendu calmez vous les
amis aujourd'hui un thread encore en
cours ou peut-être qu'il sera terminé au
moins la vidéo sort mais alors où je
suis tourner la vidéo il est encore en
cours et ça ça me fait plaisir parce
qu'à chaque fois que j'arrive après la
guerre mais pas cette fois mon ami de
plus ce serait à des français la patrie
la coupe du monde je sais pas encore si
on la gagne et [ __ ] j'espère bordel il
toit est cool
alors j'espère qu'il va vous plaire en
tout cas il va vous faire mal dormir ça
c'est sûr c'est sûr tout a commencé le 4
juillet à 22h50 lorsque mélissa alias
small est runs sur twitter a tweeté la
chose suivante
mdr nos voisins d'appart juste au-dessus
blues les mobs chaque nuit on vient
d'appeler la police parce qu'on n'en
peut plus et devinez ce qu'ils ont
découvert la partie vide et inhabitée
mec juste le début il est fou c'est
incroyable comme brive mélissa nous
informe avoir aménagé dans cet
appartement il ya environ cinq mois elle
donne des caractéristiques techniques
elle nous dit que c'est un petit
immeuble de quatre étages qu'elle habite
au troisième est que le 4e étage
contient un seul unique appartement qui
est plus grand du coup que ceux des
autres étages
elle précise qu'elle a toujours pensé
qu'il était habité parce que
régulièrement elle entend des bruits de
meubles qui bouge et j'avoue pour avoir
buté en appartement ce crédible c'est
vrai qu'il est fréquent d'entendre
beaucoup de bruit venant du dessus
puisque ton plafond c'est le solde de
tes voisins comme un truc tombe bas ça
fait un bruit du coup dans ton parfum
bref mais les à nous explique qu'elle
ait jamais montée se plaindre parce que
elle est très timide de nature et c'est
vrai javou mec même moi quand il ya du
bruit je déteste devoir aller toquer ou
déjà un truc si je me sens mal je n'aime
pas faire ça mélissa décide ensuite de
partir en vacances avec ses amis ben oui
quelle bonne idée en auvergne à une
moins bonne idée tiendront à ces foscam
les vernir les vacances se terminent
mélissa rentrer et elle décide d'inviter
ses amis à dormir chez elle parce que
voilà un petit peu de nostalgie c'est la
fin des vacances s'ils voulaient
prolonger un peu le truc mais problème
au moment de dormir
des bruits venant
comme d'aimables qui sont déplacés dans
l'appartement du dessus alors ses amis
commencent à se plaindre et mélissa leur
explique que ça fait pas mal de temps
que c'est comme ça et qu'ils vont devoir
faire avec six vols dormir ils vont
alors conseillé à mélissa d'appeler la
police pour enquêter sur ce truc
au cas où il se passe des choses pas
nettes au dessus de chézelles genre
quelqu'un qui traîne un cadavre sur le
sol par exemple je dis ça j'ai la police
arrive mélissa les amène devant la porte
de l'appartement du quatrième les
policiers parviennent facilement à
ouvrir la porte puisqu'elle n'était pas
fermée à clé et il tombe sur un
appartement complètement vide avec ni
meubles ni quelqu'un à l'intérieur les
policiers vous alors quitté les lieux en
expliquant à mélissa qui a rien dans la
part du dessus et en étant un peu vénère
parce qu'ils pensent que mélissa et ses
amis leur ont fait une mauvaise blague
elle donne rendez vous aux gens le soir
pour les tenir au courant de 6 à re des
bruits elle dit qu'elle en touchera un
nouveau propriétaire pour voir si c'est
quelque chose là dessus à partir de la
mêlée ça va pas donner nouvelle le soir
donc on suppose qui a pas eu de bruit
mais va donner des nouvelles en début
d'après-midi le 7 juillet le lendemain à
14h sa voisine s'est évanoui dans les
escaliers de l'immeuble
elle nous explique elle a juste voulu
partir faire un tour et qu'elle a vu le
camion de pompiers devant l'immeuble
avec un petit amas de voisins autour
mais laisse à pense que c'est un truc
assez grave puis 20 minutes plus tard
avec tweeds qu'en fait elle a rien de
grave tout va bien c'est juste ces
histoires de bruit alors que la parte
évident qu'ils travaillent sur son
cerveau elle se met à imaginer des trucs
alors qu' à rien un peu plus tard dans
l'après-midi bonne nouvelle mais lis ça
nous dit qu'elle a appelé le
propriétaire de l'appartement du dessus
magnifique ce dernier a apparemment bien
réagi après le truc au sérieux et a
promis à mélissa d'aller faire un tour
pour voir s'il ya pas de squatters mais
comme ils ferment tout le temps là par
tsahal étonnerait beaucoup mais c'est
parce que les policiers ont dit
l'appartement n'était pas fermé quand
ils sont rentrés dans ce dernier alors
est ce que comme c'est régulièrement le
cas c'est des squatteurs qui viennent la
nuit pour dormir dans l'appartement
on veut savoir mehdi sahnoune et ensuite
qu'une amie va venir dormir chez elle le
soir et que si elle entend de nouveau
des bruits elle montera au quatrième
étage voit ce qui se passe de ses
propres yeux mélissa respect perso
jamais j'y vais et devinez quoi
le soir même à 00h04 qui c'est qui fait
un tweet ces milices il vient de se
passer un truc très très flippant là par
contre au [ __ ] mélissa et son ami
commence à entendre des bruits venir de
l'appartement
dessus elle nous dit alors qu'à ce
moment là il ya un énorme bruit qu'ça
jamais été aussi fort alors déjà pauvres
ou chat mélissa nous on veut comme tu
l'as dit que tu monte à l'étagé alors
c'est vrai qu'on va essayer de monter
tout à l'heure si on trouve le courage
on vous tient au courant
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut lire mes
dessins les minutes passent on n'a
aucune nouvelle et à 00h32 mélissa
trouve enfin le courage de monter au
quatrième étage
la porte est fermée bordel de merde
comme mélissa je pense qu'on aurait tous
préféré qu'elle soit ouverte etc en
l'ouvrant on tombe sur des squatteurs ce
qui aurait expliqué les bruits
maintenant la porte et [ __ ] de fermer
alors est ce que quelqu'un a trouvé la
clé a fait un double un jour dans le dos
du proprio on sait pas [ __ ] sur
twitter les gens deviennent fous ils
veulent absolument savoir ce que c'est
que ces [ __ ] de bruit alors il
pourrait mettre plusieurs hypothèses qui
effectivement sont plausibles une
fenêtre cassée
bah oui avec le vent effectivement ça
pourrait faire claquer la fenêtre ou un
truc du genre des animaux coincés
ça arrive très souvent bien plus qu'on
ne le pense des oiseaux qui sont coincés
dans le toit ou des rats qui sont dans
les murs bref y'a des tas d'animaux qui
peut faire du bruit en fait dans un
immeuble en réalité ou les canalisations
effectivement si plancton prépare un
mauvais coup dans les canalisations sa
s'entendraient et le lendemain matin
mais les ça va appeler son proprio pour
lui expliquer que les bruits continue
d'être là pour lui demander de vérifier
ces fameuses hypothèses ou lui donner
une clé pour qu'elle vérifie par
elle-même et pim le proprio le prend
très mal parce qu'ils croient que mélé
savent juste gratté une clé de la partie
pour faire des fêtes dedans mais laissa
passer une après midi tranquille au parc
ou à jouer à dofus pendant sait rien et
le soir elle redonne des nouvelles et là
c'est chaud elle nous explique qu'elle
est allée voir la voisine qui avait fait
un malaise dans les escaliers il se
trouve que c'est sa voisine de palier
elle habite dans l'appartement en face
de chez elle elle a à peu près trente
ans les deux elles se connaissent pas
beaucoup mais discute quand elles se
croisent voilà vraiment comme des
voisins
sa voisine après avoir ouvert la porte
lui a parlé un peu froid de montréal lui
a expliqué qu'elle voulait pas parler de
ce qui s'était passé comme si elle avait
honte et mélissa a pas voulu insister
jusque là aucun problème c'est normal
mais attendez mélissa va se met à lui
parler des bruits qui proviennent de
l'appartement du quatrième étage pour
voir si elle aussi elle a remarqué et là
le regard de la voisine change et ses
yeux s'écarquillent cette voisine qu'on
va appeler anne dit ne rien avoir
entendu et ne pas être au courant de ces
histoires mêlées ça retourne chez elle
et c'est la carte king blizzard se passe
cinq minutes plus tard sa frappe fort à
la porte de mélissa en ouvrant elle
tombe sur anne keller con
bon perdu comme si un état aller toquer
chez mélissa dans le but de lui dire
quelque chose et qu'au moment où on veut
et ça se retrouve en face d'elle elle
avait oublié ce quelque chose mélissa va
alors accompagné anna son appartement
avant de retourner chez elle pour se
poser devant une série le lendemain
mélissa commence clairement à psychoter
elle commence à sentir mal et dans le
hall de son immeuble elle croise un
couple de personnes âgées qui remarque
qu'elle se sent pas très bien qui décide
donc de l'inviter chez eux
au premier étage ils vont alors expliqué
amélie ça qu'ils habitent dans cet
immeuble depuis des années et que les
gens n'auraient jamais très longtemps
mais surtout que personne n'a jamais
acheté l'appartement du quatrième étage
et ils vont dire étrangement que eux
aussi se sentent pas très bien mais que
ça les dérange pas ok mais même si tu
sens que tu te sens pas bien dans
l'endroit où tu vis tes sont ces cas ces
gros du moins si tu en as les moyens qu
elle rentre chez elle
on s'entend bien et là pas de nouvelles
jusqu'au lendemain mélissa va toquer à
la porte aux ânes parce qu'elle n'a pas
une nouvelle de cette dernière depuis
qu'elle est venue toquer chez elle pour
rien lui dire anne ouvre la porte et là
commence une discussion un peu à sens
unique
il ya juste mélissa qui va parler et
anne va faire uniquement des réponses
fermes et comme si elles étaient
dérangés par la présence de mélissa
c'est un peu comme s'ils en avaient deux
personnalités et que l'une de ces deux
personnalités voulais vraiment pas voir
mélissa et que quand l'autre
personnalité fait un pas vers mélissa
c'est la deuxième qui prend le dessus
empêchant la première d' envoyé un sos
finalement mélissa ventes chez elle
quelques minutes plus tard quelqu'un
toque à sa porte elle tant qu
apparemment depuis un moment donc
mélissa décide de prendre une vidéo et
de nous montrer elle a ensuite filmé à
travers l'oeil et de la porte et devinez
qui cet ami qu'elle a pu seulement
quelques minutes plus tôt mélissa se
chient littéralement dessus et décide de
ne pas les ouvrir ce que j'aurai aussi
fait clairement et elle nous dit
seulement dix minutes plus tard que
hannah enfin bouger du palier alléluia
le lendemain elle s'en veut elle décide
d'aller toquer chez anne pour lui
demander pourquoi anna toquer chez elle
la veille au soir
et en ouvrant la porte am nous comprend
pas elle lui dit ne jamais être allé
toquer chez elle la veille au soir
c'est bizarre comme comportement mélissa
donc je viens de dire le nom pour la 61e
fois dans cette vidéo je m'excuse va
alors retourné voir les petits vue du
premier étage qui sont les seules
personnes qui ont été cool avec elle
depuis qu'elle vit ce cauchemar sauf que
cette fois ça va pas se passer comme
prévu
les deux personnes âgées vont dire à
mélissa qui la trouvent très intrusive
qu'elle ferait mieux d'arrêter de se
mêler de cette histoire c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont froids avec
elle
le lendemain à savoir aujourd'hui au
moment où je tire de cette vidéo mélissa
a tweeté il ya 6 heures ce qui est bien
c'est que moi ça ne rentre pas dans mon
appart pour l'instant elle est donc
convaincu qui se passe définitivement
tout pas normal dans son immeuble et son
dernier tweet ou moi je fais cette vidéo
est le suivant beaucoup de voisins sont
partis en vacances le courrier
s'accumulent dans certaines boîtes aux
lettres
si je me retrouve seul dans l'immeuble
je vais péter les plombs on a gagné
[ __ ] les amis deux jours ont passé
depuis la fin du thread au moment où
j'avais tourné la première partie de la
vidéo il s'est passé pas mal de trucs
autour de cet immeuble de mélissa est
cet appartement laissez moi vous
raconter mélissa entend des bruits qui
viennent du hall de l'immeuble
elle décide alors pour se rassurer de
lancer un live et d'aller voir ce qui se
passe dans le hall en direct le live n'a
pas duré très longtemps parce qu'un truc
imprévu s'est passé là [ __ ] de
voisiner trong a mêlé sa sert a mené à
ce moment là donc on comprend qu'elle
ait eu un peu peur sauf que le temps
passe et la voisine ne bouge pas de cet
endroit mélissa décide alors de
retourner dans son appartement et ne pas
chercher à comprendre ce qui se passe ne
pas aller lui parler parce que là c'est
chelou et flippant quand même elle va
ensuite faire une petite crise de nerfs
et décidé d'ouvrir sa fenêtre pour
prendre l'air il est 3h30 du matin et
mélissa voit que l'appartement de ses
voisins âgés premier étage est allumée
sauf qu'elle ne voit pas de zoom
elle voit trois ou quatre ombres ses
voisins étant des personnes âgées autour
de 70 ans il trouve ça étrange qu'ils
fassent la fête à 3h30 du matin avec des
amis mais laissa ensuite acheter un
bouquin dont elle ne donne pas le nom
mais dont des passages du font penser à
sa situation on peut entre autres y lire
une entité ou un esprit que l'on appelle
aussi fantôme peut se fixer dans les
murs d'une maison ou de tout autre lieu
et polluent la vie des personnes qui les
fréquentent cet esprit va déranger ou
terroriser les vivants par des bruits
divers portes qui claquent fenêtres qui
s'ouvrent sans raison le livre a ensuite
donné les symptômes qui permettent
d'identifier une attaque paranormal une
attaque par normal détourne assurément
la victime de la réalité en la plongeant
dans une grande confusion mentale des
pensées négatives des obsessions voire
des passages amnésique
en conséquence celle ci peut se livrer à
des actes de violences sur elle même ou
sur autrui comme elle a perdu sur les
bras arbitres
elle va agir au par les concerts volonté
parfois dans des langues inconnues elle
n'a plus de contrôle sur elle même c'est
le démon kia
et parle à travers alors est ce qu est
la voisine de palier mélissa où les
petits vieux du premier étage sont
victimes d'une attaque paranormal seule
demande le lendemain sa toque à la porte
de mélissa en ouvrant la porte elle
tombe sur le couple de personnes âgées
du premier étage qui lui montrent si
tout va bien et surtout si elle veut
venir fêter le 14 juillet avec eux avec
tout ce qu'elle vient de vivre toutes
les pensées négatives qu'elle a eu une
ambiance bizarre qui a dans l'immeuble
elle se dit que ça peut être une bonne
idée effectivement d'aller fêter le 14
juillet avec eux qu'elle a sûrement
psychoter et qu'ils étaient debout à
3h30 du matin pour os x ou y raison
peut-être juste y faisait la fête à 70
ans on peut encore faire la fête un
stage là elle se retrouve donc dans un
appartement au milieu d'une fête où
personne ne se parle trop l'ambiance est
un peu bizarre mais bon ces gens de 70
ans peut-être que ça se passe comme ça
mélissa ça m'inquiète pas plus que ça au
moins ça la fait sortir et penser un peu
à autre chose et puis aussi c'est lui
permet d'en savoir plus sur ses voisins
du premier étage qui souvenez vous lui
avez dit allez occupe tout un peu tes
affaires arrêt de poser des questions
sur tout ça le temps passe à cette
soirée mélissa se fait un peu chier et
d'un coup tout le monde commence à se
prendre par la main mélissa comprend pas
ce qui se passe elle comprend encore
moins en voyant que ces gens commencent
à mettre des masques d'animaux elle part
alors en courant elle pousse une porte
de l'appartement pour se réfugier dans
une autre pièce elle tombe sur une pièce
plongée dans le noir dans laquelle se
trouve juste en plein milieu un cercle
de bougies elle se précipite sur la
planète pour l'ouvrir mais cette
dernière est bloquée elle entend les
bruits de pas dans le couloir de gens
qui commencent à se diriger vers sa
pièce elle est complètement piégée elle
s'assoit et c'est pour quoi faire et
elle se réveille parce qu'en fait elle
venue tout simplement de faire un
cauchemar à cause de ses lectures de la
veille au soir le livre laqué parlé d'
attaque paranormal tout ça c'était ya
deux heures au moment où je tourne la
vidéo j'en sais pas plus
elle a juste dit ensuite qu'elle était
terrifiée et [ __ ] j'ai envie de savoir
la suite les amis c'est la fin de ce
raid n'hésitez pas à aller mais si vous
a plu bien évidemment tout ça est une
histoire inventée de toutes pièces par
mélissa mais [ __ ] c'est bien raconté
ça fait un peu flipper et des voisins
peu chelou on en a tous eu je me demande
quelle va être la suite de l'histoire
qui sera sûrement sortie d'ailleurs au
moment où chants cette vidéo il ya le
lien du serait dans la description si
vous voulez aller voir bravo mélissa
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo il
est temps pour moi de me changer les
idées pouvoir dormir cette nuit tout
simplement aurevoir
[Musique]